une citrouille de potiron trois couches
de potimarron la petite caméra m'a
confié sa liste de courses je devrai
trouver tout ça ici je suis en touraine
au château du rivau derrière ces murs il
ya 14 au jardin d'enfants où ne poussent
que des citrouilles et des potirons
on y va ce château date du 15ème siècle
rabelais qui est né dans le secteur nous
sommes dans la région de chine ont ils
fait allusion dans son roman gargan toi
le géant du même nom offre ce château au
capitaine tollemer pour le récompenser
de sa victoire lors des guerres
picrocholines
[Musique]
on a toutes les formes de toutes les
tailles de toutes les couleurs jamais me
retrouver
tant pis je rentre à l'atelier pour
éclaircir tout ça citrouilles potirons
c'est vrai qu'on a un peu de mal à s'y
retrouver faut dire que ces deux là
appartiennent à la même famille
une immense famille les courges qui
compte plus de 1000 variétés on y
retrouve les courgettes les concombres
les cornichons et les pastèques les
melons et les gourdes qui ont donné leur
nom récipient qui permet de transporter
de l'eau était à l'origine des fruits
les potirons et les citrouilles
également qui appartiennent au genre
autrement dit une branche de cette
famille cucurbita le problème c'est
qu'en fonction de la région se trouve
citrouilles et potirons ne désigne pas
toujours le même cucurbita alors comment
s'y retrouver
je vous préviens je n'ai pas réglé le
problème d'un coup de baguette magique
au 19e siècle un botaniste français
charles naudin a réussi à mettre un peu
d'ordre là dedans les observant de très
près il a remarqué certains détails qui
permettent de distinguer les citrouilles
des potirons pour tous nos rivaux
allez c'est parti premier indice
l'aspect les vrais si tu roules
curcubitacé peau une forme allongée
comme cette citrouille de touraine elle
peut peser jusqu'à 18 kg
en général elle est cultivée pour
l'alimentation du bétail mais on peut
aussi en faire des soupes et les
confitures
les vrais potes iront eux sont plus
volumineux plus rond plus dodue ça se
voit très bien sur le rouge vif des
tentes ou sur le jaune gros de paris que
cure bitat pepo pour les citrouilles
cucurbita maxima pour les potirons c'est
charles naudin et qui les a baptisés et
comme tous les botanistes les noms qu'il
leur a donné
ne sont pas anodins deuxième indice le
pédoncule il est dur avec des angles
bien marquer et peu ces vases est à la
base de la citrouille
alors que sur le potiron et arrondies et
ressemble à un bouchon de liège un peu
spongieux et maintenant on va faire un
petit test voici un patisseau alors à
votre avis s'ils trouvent au potiron
elle sa forme ne soit pas allonger c'est
une citrouille ça se voit au niveau du
pédoncule il avait côte bien marquer et
il sait l'az à la base du fruit et celui
ci citrouilles potirons rassurez vous il
n'est pas malade il pousse comme ça
c'est un gars le d'eysines et c'est un
potiron comme en témoigne sa forme bien
ronde bien au du et son pédoncule
spongieux comme un bouchon liège
là où ça se complique c'est avec
cendrillon maintenant que vous savez
reconnaître un citrouille d'un potiron
comment notre future princesse est elle
allait au bal
retour au texte dans la version
originale du compte publier en 1697
charles perrault raconte que la jeune
femme part chercher la plus belle les
citrouilles de son genre et il semble
bien que ce soit une citrouille
cucurbita pepo gustave doré le célèbre
illustrateur représente dans les
éditions anciennes du 19e siècle
seulement voilà au début du 20e siècle
les illustrateurs commence à dessiner
des cucurbitacées qui ressemblent
davantage à des potirons cas des
citrouilles et le dessin animé de walt
disney en ajoute encore une couche
tandis que l'histoire parle toujours de
citrouille
c'est un potiron que la tante de
cendrillon transforme en carrosse il
faut dire qu'à potiron ça peut être
énorme le plus gros du monde a été
récolté en 2016 en belgique il pesait
1200 kg le poids d'une voiture ou d'un
carrosse d'où peut-être l'origine de la
confusion quand il en soit cet éclairage
était nécessaire je tiens au fait en
parlant d'éclairage pourquoi krostons
des lanternes dans les citrouilles au
moment d'halloween
ah oui je sais c'est une fête d'origine
celte ses racines se retrouve dans une
ancienne fête irlandaise ça mail
j'espère que je prononce bien célébrée
le 31 octobre et le 1er novembre elle
marque la fin de la saison des récoltes
et le début de l'hiver à l'époque on
pensait que durant cette période de
l'année est la frontière entre le monde
des vivants et celui des morts était
totalement poreuse et que les esprits
pouvait communiquer avec les hommes
c'était l'occasion d'allumer des grands
feux de jouer des tours en se déguisant
morts-vivants et de creuser des
lanternes
non pas dans des citrouilles mais dans
je vous montrais
dans un avis au milieu du 19e siècle la
grande famine pousse des millions
d'irlandais a quitté leur pays pour les
états unis ils emmènent leur culture et
leurs traditions seulement le navet ne
pousse pas très bien en amérique du nord
pour la fête d'halloween
il est remplacé par des citrouilles qui
j'avais oublié de vous le préciser sont
originaires du nouveau monde ce sont les
conquistadors et qui les ont rapportés
en europe au début du 16e siècle la
citrouille remplace donc le navet pour
la fête d'halloween
elle en devient même le symbole en
particulier la jack o'lantern celle ci
elle tient son nom d'une ancienne
légende irlandaise
jack à la lanterne condamnée par le
diable à errer pour l'éternité dans
l'obscurité
nous sommes aussi dans un marché devenu
une citrouille
ça va vous me suivez moi j'ai la tête
comme une citrouille et en plus je n'ai
pas encore fait les courses pour la
petite caméra aller j'y vais à bientôt
le moment est maintenant venu de
répondre à vos questions depuis le début
de cette aventure vous êtes très
nombreux à m'interroger sur les
différents sujets que je traite dans mes
vidéos aujourd'hui j'ai donc répondre à
quelques questions sur la moutarde revox
me demande si la moutade présente des
risques pour la santé ou si elle possède
des vertus et bien après de nombreux
diététiciens la moutarde contient
beaucoup de vitamine c on y trouve
également de la vitamine b2 b6 et b9
ainsi que du magnésium et du calcium
rien des nutriments qui apporte de
l'énergie à l'organisme bon vous n'êtes
pas non plus obligé d'en avaler 3
cuillères et au petit déjeuner une
question moins drôle mais qui revient
souvent
quel rapport entre la moutarde et le
sinistre gaz du même nom utilisé comme
arme chimique pendant la première guerre
mondiale notamment et bien aucun rapport
si ce gaz a été baptisé gaz moutarde
c'est tout simplement parce que se
nouent d'heure dans certaines conditions
rappelle celle de la moutarde
enfin quelle différence entre la
moutarde fine et la moutarde à
l'ancienne et bien ces deux moutardes
sont fabriqués à partir des mêmes
graines qui sont broyés à ce stade on
obtient de la moutarde à l'ancienne
nounou tâte qui contient des graines et
aussi le tégument des graines notamment
dit leur enveloppe pour obtenir de la
moutarde fine et bien il faut passer
cette pâte dans une centrifugeuse à
cylindre qui tourne très vite qui va
permettre de séparer la sauce des
graines
voilà il ne reste plus qu'à vous
souhaiter une bonne dégustation
à très bientôt et je vous promets on va
continuer à se régaler citron poti
rouille potier au citron les
illustrateurs commence à dessiner des
curieux up les illustrateurs commence à
dessiner les kurdes les turcs et
cucurbitacées je bois
[Musique]